the man on the cross could not have
entered Paradise meaning
Heaven because at that time everyone
would have been in Abraham's bosom they
only entered Paradise after Jesus opened
up Heaven which would have happened
after the resurrection is that his
objection yeah okay now how do you
answer that one of two ways number one
there is evidence there is
evidence that there were two paradises
according to the Jews there was Heavenly
Paradise where God dwelt but then there
was also the paradise of shol what's
called Abraham's bsom so he's assuming
that when Jesus says today you'll be
with me in Paradise that means Heavenly
Paradise the third heaven 2 Corinthians
12 2-4 the third heaven well there is
evidence that there was also the
paradise of shol because there was a
belief that the righteous would go there
in shol but they would be in peace so
how do we know what Paradise Jesus has
in mind so it can be paradise but the
paradise of Abraham's
bom you he me there yeah makes sense
yeah okay so there are two paradises
there's evidence for it that in the time
of Jesus the Jews believe two Paradise
Heavenly and the one sh what we call
Abraham's bosom okay yeah so who's to
say that the Lord is not saying today
you will be with me
in the shol the paradise of sh which is
Abraham's bom so there's no problem but
let assume let's assume that the Lord is
talking about
heaven aren't there exceptions to the
rule let's assume Brethren that the Lord
made an exception he sent the man ahead
of him in Paradise right after he died
because his death made atonement could
there be an exception of course because
in the Bible we find exceptions
everywhere so here's what I want you to
learn learn how to interpret scripture
learn how not to interpret scripture you
must be careful of taking what's called
General statements what's a general
statement that this is a statement that
is generally true it applies generally
but there are Exceptions there are
exceptions to the rule so normally it's
appointed for a man to die once but we
know there are exceptions in the Bible
and even today in the Bible people die
to be raised to die a second time right
yeah so does that mean in Hebrews 9:27
when it says it is appointed for man to
die once that it's not possible for
someone to die and be raised to die a
second time we know that's not the case
because Jesus raised Lazarus from the
dead which means Lazarus di was raised
to die a second time gyrus daughter died
was raised to die a second time right
the Widow's son at name died was raised
to die second time and on and on goes so
there are General statements
that apply generally but there will be
exceptions to the norm another exception
is Enoch did not taste death Hebrews
11:5 the same author in Hebrews Hebrews
9:27 who says it is appointed for man to
die once and after that comes the
Judgment that same author in Hebrews
11:5 says Enoch did not taste death so
he didn't die and he was
taken out of this world and then that
same author in Hebrews 11:35 says that
people receed their dead their dead back
meaning they die they were raised which
means they'll die a second time so could
it be possible that this thief on the
cross is an exception everyone goes to
shol but the Lord knowing he's going to
accomplish Redemption once they die he
will then summon his soul to enter
Paradise
as the deposit that the rest are going
to follow because he's accomplished
Redemption that's possible